you write about this experience where
you hitchhiked in the city and you got
picked up by a truck driver yeah and I'm
going there is no [__] way Andy Cohen
is going around hitchhiking first of all
hitchhiking who's [__] hitchhiking
you don't have a driver I was not
hitchhiking I was standing trying to get
a cab and no one was coming and this
truck driver goes where are you going
and I told him and he picked me up and I
got in the car and you got in of course
I did I needed to write that and then a
weekend and then like five days later
there were no Ubers in sight it was one
in the morning and I'm standing there
looking for a cab and this couple pulls
over and they go are you Andy Cohen I go
yeah they go where are you going I said
23rd between 7th and sixth they said
we'll take you and I said great I'll
take it right when I can't get a cab you
are out of your mind why Andy yeah
you're working your ass off yeah doing a
radio show you're doing the show at
night you're you're running the Bravo
thing with real housewife eyes treat
yourself okay live a little all right I
mean where does this come from I take
the subway to sirius it's the quickest
way to get to see what yes what happens
when you go down to the subway people
you're highly recogn do you wear it in
Disguise absolutely listen I dropped my
kid off at school I want to get here I
go to Toasties to get my breakfast I
like I have [__] that I need to do I
know about your upbringing in St Louis
and your mother was very very focused on
keeping you grounded she took you to the
juvenile delinquent Center so that you
would know that you're privileged yes
this makes sense to me you know that I
do know that about you and in a way I
think you're trying to prove to your
mother look how grounded I am prove to
anyone I'm trying to get to Serious in
the quickest amount of time by the way
after
9 11. I used to take the subway all the
time after 9 11 I started taking cabs to
Midtown to get to Bravo because I didn't
want to be underground and the truth of
the and finally I folded years later
because I was like the truth of the
matter is during rush hour the quickest
way into Midtown is on the train what do
you do when you're down in the subway
yeah and one of these maniacs
starts acting out there was a time
actually I think it's in the book where
Amy Sedaris and I were going to the Polo
Bar for dinner and I said let's take the
E train and we took the train and I said
what could happen she was like it was
around the time where people were
starting to go back in the Subways again
after the latest covid or whatever and I
said what could happen and we went down
there and there was a man doing all
sorts of [__] and she was like this is
how we're gonna meet our end because you
wanted to take the subway to the Polo
Bar
foreign